hi I'm Ralph Macchio and this is the
wired auto complete interview
have I ever Googled myself
I'd love to say no but of course who
hasn't it's a dangerous and slippery
slope
okay who is Ralph Macchio in Cobra Kai
really someone Google that Ralph Macho
is Daniel Larusso in Cobra Kai it's as
unique an experience playing a character
30 years later that everyone grew up
with and then finding flaws in this
character as an adult that were
different from the flaws maybe as he was
as a teenager that exploration is for an
actor is so
um fulfilling to see people a younger
generation latch on to it it's pretty
awesome who taught Ralph Macchio karate
that would be a gentleman by the name of
Pat E Johnson if you've seen the Karate
Kid film he played the referee in the
final tournament and that was Pat
Johnson he taught all of us trained Me
In gojiru Style Okinawan classic karate
and Pat Morita as well he was a big part
of creating all those those sequences
who is Ralph Macchio best friend well
that's tough now I'm calling out
everybody I know I have a few great
friends my wife is my best friend it
sounds like the Diplomatic answer but it
is a truthful answer we have been
married 35 years and are blessed with
two great adult kids though come on how
is that possible so we move on
okay how was Ralph Macchio discovered
interestingly I was at a dance recital
some Talent agents saw me and I went in
on a few commercials and I got a Bubble
Yum commercial how many karate movies
with Ralph one
two three karate movies with Ralph it's
as simple as that now this
machio
I was never good at following
instructions how many
languages does Ralph Macchio speak
English and New York that's all I got
that's enough with that
does Ralph Macchio respond to fan mail
early on in my career all the time
getting them reading them writing back
signing pictures as things started to
grow it was a little less easy to do and
then what you end up doing is insulting
all the people that you didn't answer so
then it's try to be good and it's it
kicks your back in the butt it would be
wonderful to answer everyone back you
try to answer it back with with good
work and cheers you know that's that's
the best uh the best I could do does
Ralph Macchio have a black belt no it's
eggshell kind of beige I know a little
more martial arts than that but I do not
have a black belt does Ralph Macchio use
a stunt double most often I don't I
really try to do all the stuff certainly
it was easier back in the day yeah I've
hurt myself a few times you know I've
never broken anything that's just made
the biggest mistake ever saying that out
loud does Ralph Macchio
play guitar it all depends on what play
guitar means to you I do play a little
basic guitar of doing this movie
Crossroads where I really learned blues
guitar classical guitar electric
acoustic but it was all done to play
back by the professionals all right
there's that
next is Ralph Macchio left-handed no
that's why when they said to hold this
on this side it's like what wait I can't
pull with the left hand but I'm doing
I'm doing okay is Ralph Macchio from New
Jersey no he's from New York Daniel
Larusso the The Karate Kid characters
from Newark New Jersey and people just
don't want to believe that I'm not from
Newark New Jersey
is Ralph Macchio vegan no he'd like to
be I say I'm gonna do this I don't need
the steak
and then sometimes I I knuckle under
listen I'm not done living next time I
come back might be a different answer is
Ralph Macchio a nice guy should I let
you all in on the secret this whole good
guy thing has just been a facade for
decades on end I do try to put my best
foot forward and I think it's important
you know you put it out hopefully you
get it back maybe tomorrow I'm gonna
change that all right what do we got
here
was Ralph Macchio
okay we need new glue was Ralph Macho in
Godfather 2 I wish you know one of the
greatest films ever made I did work with
Francis Ford Coppola who directed
Godfather II he directed The Outsiders
film I'm proud of so that's as close as
I got I mean I worked with De Niro on
Broadway in a play called Cuban is teddy
bear so I have a connection I wonder why
they think I would be associated with
that film I guess
um
Italian-American
could that be it
my love for red wine that could be the
two I was going something deeper and I
was just coming up empty let's move on
was Ralph Macchio okay all right
all right was Ralph Macchio in menudo
chuckling at this I would make jokes
about my menudo-ishness but I was way
too old for the menudo kids but thank
you thank you very much for Googling
that was Ralph Macchio on Dancing I
think it's with the Stars the answer to
that is yes season 12 2011 and I didn't
suck but I didn't win nice guys finished
fourth okay next
why Ralph Macchio did you just stopped
there something I hear around the house
all the time why did Ralph Macchio stop
Karate Kid I don't think that's totally
true why did I stop Karate Kid in 1988
because it was time and then who knew
when I finished Karate Kid 3 I thought
there would be no way in hell I'd play
Daniela Russo ever again not that I
disliked but
um it was time at that point and
interestingly enough The Karate Kid 3
storyline is now giving the season five
of Cobra Kai's storyline so be careful
what you think you know why is Ralph
Macchio
thanked and Thor that's a good question
there is a Ralph Macchio that is not
this one who's involved in the Marvel
Spider-Man Stan Lee Universe I learned
this when I looked myself up at one
point and it was not me people did often
after Thor came out saying why were you
thank for that and I just you know I
pretended that I was it was in my estate
and all the money comes to me and I
played that out for a little bit why
does Ralph Macchio look
so young it's my parents fault it's good
genes it's youthful boyishness that I
lean into don't know I wish I had the my
voice is cracking see I'm finally going
through puree right now
unwired okay Ralph Macchio
book it is called Waxing on the Karate
Kid and me and it is equal parts
Nostalgia and contemporary relevance
that takes the readers through the
Journey uh through my eyes from walking
in the shoes of Daniel Larusso from 1983
up until today and the the ups and downs
and celebratory look at something that
has touched so many people as well as my
life Ralph Macchio first movie was
called up the academy it was directed by
Robert Downey Senior Downey Jr's Dad it
was an R-rated comedy for Warner
Brothers Ralph Macchio gangster movie
was that in a gangster movie Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern were Undead I played a
gangster I was in a film called a good
night to die that had gangster elements
in it as well spot Ralph Macchio
Jeopardy I got to do a run on Jeopardy
uh recently a whole category about Cobra
Kai and that was kind of fun my best
game show run
and there we go
well entertained by my Google search a
couple of surprises which is what we aim
for and a couple of yeah of course
they're gonna ask that I look forward to
doing it again and maybe I could uh have
a few highlights in life and career to
change a few of those questions